>>> WHAT YOU MIGHT CALL A
TEXAS-SIZED QUESON FOR GEORGIA
SENATE CANDATE HERSCHEL
WALKER.
CNN'S K FILE REPORTS WALKER IS
GETTING A $1500 TAX BREAK
BECAUSE HE LISTED A TEXAS HOME
AS HIS PRIMARY RESIDENCE THIS
YEAR.
A LOCAL TEXAS OFFICIAL SAYS HE
TOOK THAT FOR BOTH 2021 AND
2022.
THAT BEING AFTER LAUNCHING HIS
SENATE BID IN GEORGIA.
WALKER IS THE REPUBLICAN TRYING
TO UNSEAT SENATOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK IN A DECEMBER 6th RUNOFF
ELECTION.
OUR GREAT REPORTERS ARE BACK
WITH US.
THIS IS NOT HARD.
BASIC CAMPAIGN 101, CHECK THE
TAX FORMS, YOUR HOUSING FORMS,
EVERYTHING ELSE.
HE IS TAKING A TAX DEDUCTION ON
A PRIMARY RESIDENCE IN TEXAS
WHILE RUNNING FOR THE SENATE IN
GEORGIA.
BAD.
>> NOT GOOD.
NOT GOOD, FOLKS.
IN TERMS OF THE FACT THAT THIS
HAPPENED IN 2021 AND 2022 AFTER
LAUNCHING HIS BID POTENTIALLY
AFTER WINNING THE PRIMARY, IT
JUST SHOWS SORT OF THE LACK OF
VETTING THAT IS IN THIS PROCESS
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE IN THE
STATE OF GEORGIA IN PART BECAUSE
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
DECIDED TO GIVE HERSCHEL WALKER
HIS STAMP OF APPROVAL AND DIDN'T
NOT NEED TO BE VETTED AS A
RESULT AND VOTERS DECIDED TO
FOLLOW TRUMP'S LEAD AND NOW
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS IN GEORGIA WHO ARE
UNHAPPY WITH THE FACT THAT
HERSCHEL WALKER IS THEIR
CANDIDATE.
HE WAS TRAILING IN THE ORIGINAL
RACE AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO A
RUNOFF AND SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
THE STEAM IS RUNNING OUT OF HIS
CAMPAIGN.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN
WHEN VOTERS VOTE BUT THIS IS NOT
THE KIND OF HEADLINE YOU WANT TO
TRY TO MOTIVATE VOTERS IN
GEORGIA TO SAY THAT YOU SHOULD
REPRESENT THEM.
THERE ARE ALREADY A NUMBER OF
GEORGIANS THAT SAY HE SHOULD NOT
BE OUR REPRESENTATIVE.
THE FACT THAT HE'S CLAIMING A
TAX BREAK IN TEXAS DOESN'T HELP.
>> IT DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF ROOM
FORERER, 200,000 VOTED FOR BRIAN
KEMP WHO DID NOT VOTE FOR THE
SENATE CANDIDATE SO YOU ALREADY
HAVE A REPUBLICAN ENTHUSIASM
QUESTION.
IF YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE
HEADLINES, THE GUY WHO WANTS TO
REPRESENT YOU IS GETTING A TAX
BREAK FOR A HOUSE IN TEXAS, NOT
HELPFUL.
>> THERE'S A HUGE ENTHUSIASM
GAP.
I THINK THAT'S ONLY GOING TO
INCREASE NOW THAT DEMOCRATS FOR
SURE HAVE CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
I MEAN ADDING ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR WOULD HELP THEM IN TERMS
OF WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO DO BUT I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
MANY REPUBLICANS AND
INDEPENDENTS WHO DIDN'T VOTE FOR
WALKER THE FIRST TIME WHO ARE
INCENTIVIZED TO GET OUT AND VOTE
FOR HIM THIS TIME, RIGHT?
WE HAVE SEEN REPUBLICANS TRY TO
COUNTERACT THAT.
BRIAN KEMP IS OUT THERE WITH
LEAFLETS.
THEY'RE MAILING WITH JUST HIS
PHOTO.
WALKER ISN'T EVEN ON THEM SAYING
PLEASE SUPPORT HERSCHEL AND CUT
A DIRECT TO TV AD.
ONLY TILE WILL TELL.
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING POINT
ABOUT WHAT IS KEMP THINKING IN
THE SENSE THAT HE CAMPAIGNED
WITH WALKER OVER THE WEEKEND.
DID NOT CAMPAIGN AT ALL WITH HIM
BEFORE THE GENERAL ELECTION AND
CAMPAIGNED WITH HIM OVER THE
WEEKEND AND MENTIONED LEAFLETS
AND GOT TO DEAL WITH MITCH
McCONNELL AND THE AD YOU
MENTIONED RIGHT HERE.
>> HERSCHEL WALKER WILL VOTE FOR
GEORGIA.
THAT'S WHY I'M BACKING HERSCHEL
AND I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME IN
VOTING FOR HIM TOO.
>> DIDN'T SAY A PEEP IN THE
NORMAL ELECTION.
NOW ALL ON BOARD IN THE RUNOFF
ELECTION.
WHY?
>> I MEAN, THAT'S SOMEWHAT THE
PARTY HAS GOT TO DO TO GET HIM
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE AT THIS
POINT AND TO YOUR POINT A MOMENT
AGO I WAS TALKING TO SOMEONE
INVOLVED WITH THE CAMPAIGN IN
GEORGIA THIS MORNING AND THE
REPUBLICANS ARE HOPING THERE
WILL BE A HUGE DROP-OFF IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER OF VOTERS THAT
TURN OUT.
WE SAW SO MANY OF THOSE TICKET
SPLITTERS THIS TIME THE
KEMP/WARNOCK VOTERS, IT'S REALLY
A QUESTION, I GUESS, THAT THE
GOP IS WONDERING WHETHER THOSE
FOLKS WILL ACTUALLY BE MOTIVATED
TO TURN OUT.
AND THE BEST CASE SCENARIO FOR
THEM IS THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
PEOPLE THAT HAD AN ISSUE WITH
WALKER IN THE FIRST ROUND WILL
JUST POTENTIALLY STAY HOME.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW BIG THAT GROUP
WILL BE BUT THAT'S KIND OF THEIR
BEST BET.
>> YOU HEAR THE ARGUMENT FROM
BRIAN KEMP MAKING -- YOU NEED TO
VOTE FOR HERSCHEL WALKER TO
ESSENTIALLY CHECK JOE BIDEN.
WELL, TWO REPUBLICAN SENATORS
AND THE CURRENT SENATOR WHO KNOW
THEY WERE GOING TO SPEND THE
NEXT TWO YEARS IN THE MINORITY.
TED CRUZ AND LINDSEY GRAHAM WITH
WALKER DOING A TELEVISION
INTERVIEW.
TED CRUZ MAKING A SIMILAR POINT.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER HAS TOLD YOU,
HE DOESN'T WANT HERSCHEL WALKER
TO WIN.
HE DOESN'T WANT A 50/50 SENATE.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE IN A 50/50 SENATE THE
COMMITTEES ARE EVEN WHICH SLOWS
HIM DOWN.
IF RAPHAEL WARNOCK WINS, SCHUMER
CAN EXPEDITE CONFIRMING RADICAL
JUDGES TO TAKE AWAY YOUR FREE
SPEECH RIGHTS, YOUR RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY RIGHT, YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> G.O.T. THE EFFORT.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
INTRICACIES, 50 VERSUS 51 AND
LOSE A LOT OF SEATERS WHEN YOU
GET INTO THE WEEDS LIKE THAT SO
THIS ISN'T AS IMPORTANT IF IT
WAS GOING TO DETERMINE WHO IS
GOING TO CONTROL THE SENATE SO
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CROSS OVER AND HOLD
THEIR NOSE AND VOTE FOR HERSCHEL
WALKER IF IT MEANT CONTROL OF
THE SENATE AND A NUMBER OF THESE
DIFFERENT RIGHTS THAT SENATOR
CRUZ WAS TALKING ABOUT WERE MORE
SORT OF HANGING IN THE LURCH BUT
THIS IS GOING TO BE, YOU KNOW, A
DEMOCRATIC CONTROLLED SENATE NO
MATTER WHAT AND DEMOCRATIC
COMMITTEES WILL RUN THEM AND IT
WILL LOSE A LOT OF VOTERS AND BE
HARD TO MOTIVATE PEOPLE.
>> THE FLIP SIDE IF THE MOOD
AMONG DEMOCRATS BECOME, A, WE
HAVE THE MAJORITY NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS AND, B, WE HAVE THIS
RACE, SO I DON'T HAVE TO VOTE.
IT'S COVERED WHICH IS WHY
OBAMA'S COMING IN, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA COMING IN
DECEMBER 1st FIVE DAYS BEFORE
THE RUNOFF AND WHILE WARNOCK IS
RUNNING AN AGGRESSIVE TV AD
QUESTIONING FIRST ON WALKER'S
CHARACTER AND HERE ON WHETHER
YOU CAN TRUST HIM ON ANYTHING.
>> THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS FINISHED
VOTING AND ONLY US LEFT.
YOU THINK HERSCHEL WALKER WOULD
WANT TO EXPLAIN WHAT HE'D DO IN
THE SENATE IF HE ACTUALLY WANTS
TO REPRESENT GEORGIA.
INSTEAD HE REPEATS THE SAME
LIES, TRYING TO DISTRACT FROM
WHAT WE ALL KNOW IS TRUE ABOUT
HIM.
I THINK GEORGIANS WILL SEE THE
ADS FOR WHAT THEY ARE, DON'T
YOU?
>> WHETHER YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT OR
A REPUBLICAN OR INDEPENDENT, THE
WARNOCK ADS ARE CATCHY, THEY'VE
JUST BEEN EFFECTIVE THROUGHOUT
THE CAMPAIGN.
>> THEY DO LAND PRETTY WELL.
PEOPLE PAY ATTENTION TO THEM.
I THINK THE OTHER THING ABOUT
WARNOCK THAT'S INTERESTING IS
HE'S RUNNING A VERY CONSISTENT
MESSAGE LIKE YOU SAID, CAMPAIGN
STOPS ALL OF THIS WEEK SAYING
THE EXACT SAME THING, THIS RACE
IS ABOUT CHARACTER, IT'S ABOUT
COMPETENCE, WHY WOULD YOU GIVE
THESE POWERFUL TOOLS OF THE
SENATE TO SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
STAND UP FOR EITHER IS HIS
MESSAGE THEN ON THE OTHER SIDE
YOU HAVE HERSCHEL WALKER WHO
THERE'S JUST MORE CONTROVERSIALS
COMING OUT, THE LATEST BEING
THIS, YOU KNOW, TEXAS RESIDENCY,
SO I THINK THAT DEFINITELY WORKS
IN DEMOCRATS' FAVOR GOING INTO
THIS.
>> THE THIRD TIME WARNOCK --
FOURTH TIME HE'S HAD TO RUN FOR
THIS SEAT IN TWO YEAR, ELECTION,
RUNOFF, ELECTION --
>> HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> AND IT'S JUST HOW ON EARTH
DOES HERSCHEL WALKER LIKE DRIVE
A MESSAGE WITH DISTRACTION AFTER
DISTRACTION AND, YOU KNOW, THIS
LATEST ONE IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE
PEOPLE LOOK AT THAT AND SAY,
WELL, I DON'T HAVE THOSE
ADVANTAGES.
AND I DON'T, YOU KNOW, AND HE --
THERE'S NO WAY FOR ANYONE TO
EXPLAIN THAT.
>> AND SO YOU WANT TO LOOK AT
THE STAKE, JUST LOOK AT THE
SPENDING.
THIS IS SO FAR WE HAVE, WHAT,
TWO WEEKS TO GO, THREE WEEKS,
DEMOCRATS HAVE SPENT MORE THAN
$25 MILLION.
REPUBLICANS HAVE SPENT $16
MILLION IF YOU ROUND UP AND MORE
TO COME.
MORE TO COME.